okay so I'm cheating a little bit with
this one as a lot of people do sort of
consider this as an animated Disney
flick okay and maybe not considerate but
it's a satire of a Disney animated flick
done by Disney animation so it's kind of
hard not to talk about it
enchanted starts off in a faraway land
an animated faraway land as a handsome
prince he has an evil mother and he
wants to marry a beautiful peasant but
the mother doesn't want them to marry
and so banishes her to another Kingdom
that is to say our Kingdom the real
world yes isn't that gimmicky she comes
across a father and daughter in New York
City who take pity on her and decide to
take her in she acts the way most of the
leading females act from Disney anime
films or well more of the early ones and
it turns out she manages to bring a
little magic into their lives but then
other people start to show up including
the dashing Prince and the evil mother
the dashing Prince of course is all
smiles and heroics while the mother is
all evil and sorcery and while spending
time in the quote-unquote real world
they find out some of the ways they've
been acting in their cartoony world
doesn't seem very logical
for example the peasant decides to ask
the prince to go out on a date they also
discover that the stationary roles that
they're so used to staying in don't have
to be there all the time a woman can be
strong a man can be weak and so on and
so forth okay well you get the gist of
it so how's the movie well it does have
some good laughs in it especially just
from the performances the peasant and
the prince are especially funny I mean
they just crack me up whenever they're
on screen and I do like the fact that as
much as our world tries to force reality
on them their world can force their
magic on to us like sometimes they'll
break into song sequences animals will
suddenly be cleaning up all that good
stuff
I guess what bothers me a little bit is
the fact that it is a Disney film and
that really what they're satirizing is
more over-the-top than they give it
credit for I mean number one the films
they're satirizing really are the films
like Snow White and Cinderella the more
modern fairy tales don't quite go as
this goofy that is except for this one
line and this does make me laugh
and you are to sow Oh Giselle we shall
be married in the morning
that is fought on but aside from that
the whole idea that the princesses
always have to be damsels and that the
princes always have to save the day I
don't know it seems like with Beauty and
the Beast and Mulan Aladdin and stuff
they've mixed it up a bit
I mean okay it's not perfect and they do
sometimes go back into those roles but I
think even Disney knows that they've
come further than this movie is giving
him credit for on top of that it works
when they're playing it up for Laughs
but the last third where Susan Sarandon
is quoting every obvious stereotype man
does that get annoying this is a twist
on our story it's the brave little
princess I guess that makes you the
damsel in distress we're coming to the
end of our story now and they all lived
happily ever after
it's time to take our tails
like dying no our dad yes we get it
things are switched around whoo
see in my opinion when you really want
change to happen you just sort of do it
you don't draw a ton of attention to it
I guess I'm very much a by example
person that way here when you draw too
much attention to it it sort of feels
like you're focusing on a stereotype
that you may or may not have known
existed like maybe you had a girl who
was a tomboy and wasn't into princesses
and then you find out oh you were
supposed to be this way but now we're
telling you it's okay or how about a boy
who wasn't into fighting and rescues but
then you find out oh no this is what
you're supposed to be except now we've
given you permission not to be then
again maybe by drawing more attention to
it they feel like they're slapping the
issue in the face but I don't know isn't
the female lead holding a sword not
really that shocking anymore isn't the
fact that a guy has to be rescued once
in a while not so risque I wouldn't
dwell on so much except for the fact
that the movie dwells on it so much but
let's be honest what enchanting really
wanted to be was a romantic comedy for
kids but mostly for adults so in a sense
they overplayed the childish stereotypes
because well it'll get a bigger laugh
out of the adults because that's what
they remember growing up with Snow White
Cinderella and so forth I guess I just
get a little nervous thinking that this
could possibly be a kid's first Disney
movie when obviously it's satirizing
Disney movies and even then not
phenomenally well I mean it's funny but
more for the characters they create not
for the ones they're satirizing so kind
of a mixed bag but I find I do enjoy it
can we get down to it I guess it is
harmless enough but what would this mean
for Disney would this mean that the 2d
animation studio is back after such a
long and horrible hiatus well we'll find
out in the next film
you